[Music]
all right hello hi um your speech
tonight was so inspiring
I know okay hi hi your speech tonight
was so amazing and inspirational I'd
love to know what you feel is the
greatest lesson you've learned
throughout your life and career
the greatest lesson I've learned
throughout my career came from Maya
Angelou actually when I was you know
first meeting her and after I'd known
her for a while she said baby you know
you need to know that when people show
you who they are you believe them the
first time oh you know that lesson too
now first time and your problem is it
takes you 29 times to see the same
lesson coming in a different skirt or
wearing a different pair of pants so I
think that has been one of my greatest
wisdom teachings is to assess from
people's behavior their actions not just
towards me but towards other people who
they are and how they behave because if
people talk about other people they'll
talk about you so I think in business
and in personal relationships that's
also been my greatest lesson also
staying grounded you know has been
really great for me yes sir hi in the
back to you yes yes that's you hello
congratulations Francisco Varela from
Telemundo thank you you are on top of
the world will love you
what humbles you right now what humbles
me yes this humbles me when I first got
when they first call me and said they
wanted me to accept this I said I
shouldn't be the person to get the Cecil
B deMille Award you know why I was
working with Reese Witherspoon this past
spring and winter and I happened to just
say in the makeup room one morning I
said so how many movies have you done
she goes oh honey child I don't know I
don't know it's been so many and I then
thought I hope she doesn't ask me
because I think it's been five and so I
I didn't understand it and then they
explained that it's about overall
entertainment now what I was able to do
with the Oprah show and the cultural
statement we were able to make
throughout the world I feel very very
very proud of that but I think that when
it comes to films that I am really the
new kid on the block and I always feel
like when I'm acting that I am you know
out of my box and it's the most
intimidated I ever feel mr. a gold fast
hello I'm curious what wisdom you could
pass on to me and my friends were film
school scholarship recipients at the
Hollywood Foreign Press I'm curious what
wisdom can you pass on to the future
generation of people here in Hollywood I
want to make me well the way to make
movies is to do stuff that you love
because you know for 25 years I worked
on The Oprah Show and Stedman will tell
you that there were date nights that I
came home and I almost you know it's
hard to even like take off my clothes
because I knew I was gonna be getting up
for hours later but I never really felt
exhausted like Dipel too exhausted but I
never felt depleted so do the work that
comes straight from the soul of you from
your background from stories that you've
grown up with from stories that bring
you passion from stories that you not
just yearn to tell but that if you don't
tell them they won't get told and when
you when you are operating you know the
single the single greatest wisdom I
think I've ever received other than when
people show who they are is that the key
to fulfillment success happiness
contentment in life is when you align
your personality with what your soul
actually came to do I believe everybody
has a soul and has you know their own
personal spiritual energy so when you
can use your personality to serve
whatever that thing is you can't help
but be successful so if you do films
that come from the interior of your soul
you do work you do art that comes from
the interior of you
you cannot miss it's only when you're
doing stuff that you think might make
money you think it may be a hit or you
think it may bring you some level of
attention or success that isn't what
does it I would have to say that all of
the great wonderful experiences of my
life that have brought me to this moment
have come from working from the interior
of myself and so that's why it feels so
authentic because it it actually is so
when you do that you'll win okay hi
Oprah hi I'm right back here there you
are
you always give such sage advice to
everyone else and I'm just curious as
you look over your life what advice
would you give to seven-year-old /
Arthur T about surviving as a woman in
this world 7 I was so sad and at seven
all of my real love came from my
teachers and so my teachers I would say
this to anybody in this room you have no
idea of the power of noticing another
human being and what it feels like when
somebody knows that they have been seen
truly seen by you it is the greatest
offering you can give and all those
years of the Oprah show the greatest
lesson I learned was that you know after
every show someone would say invariably
in one way or another how is that I
finished an interview with father who
killed his twin daughters I finished an
interview with politician Barack Obama
Joe Biden George Bush they Beyonce they
all say the same thing how was that and
so I started to see that there's this
common thread in our humanity where
everybody wants to know how was that did
I do okay did you hear me and did what I
say means something to you so I would
have to say that recognizing that in
other people has helped me to become you
know a person of compassion a person of
understanding person who can interview
anybody
about anything because I know that it
the core of you is the same as core me
you just want to be heard so yes Oprah
directly actually Oprah directly in
front of you directly directly GMA
Philippines last year when Meryl Streep
won this award I felt a very different
time Trump had just won we had all the
allegations last year with your speech
with everyone in you know solidary
solidarity and black tonight do you feel
like the country together as a whole is
moving in a better direction than we
moved last year I certainly feel that
what happened you know I always think
and no having watched it over the years
through thousands of thousands of
interviews and watching people in their
dysfunction that when something really
negative is brewing that there is the
direct opposite reaction that is also
possible because for every action
there's an equal and opposite reaction
so when something is big as what started
to happen in October with Harvey
Weinstein started to unfold I thought
whoa whoa whoa and with every day's
revelation I thought here is an
opportunity for something powerfully a
powerful growth and how do we use this
moment to elevate what is happening
instead of victim continually victimize
ourselves and so I think that wearing
black in solidarity is one step I think
that what time's up is doing with the
Legal Defense Fund is a major step was
very important to all of us involved
with times up that it not just be about
the women of Hollywood because we're
already a privileged group but to extend
to the women of the world because as I
said tonight there isn't a culture a
race a religion a politic a workplace
that hasn't been affected by it and one
of the reasons why
to tell Ricci Taylor's story is to let
people know it's been happening for a
very long time when people didn't feel
that they could speak up and so there
are so many women who've endured so much
and remained silent and kept going
because there was no other recourse and
now that we've all joined as one voice I
think that those it is feels like
empowerment to those women who never had
it